If I had the power to change something
for young people in Europe,
I would tell them that they have the right
of co-decision on policy.
At school we were taught to just follow
the rules, but that's not true.
We can co-decide on the rules and in
that way make a better youth policy.
Structured Dialogue
is an initiative of Europe.
It connects young people and
policymakers in a structured way
in order to draw up policy proposals.
During the conference
I got to meet a policymaker.
We exchanged some ideas.
He was very interested
in what I had to say,
what I had learned,
what I was involved in.
He stood much closer to the youth
than I had imagined.
That was a very interesting discussion
I had with Ines
because clearly she comes
from a very participatory background.
She's a chairwoman
of a local youth council
and I was quite impressed
because she's very well informed
about the way participation
happens at local level,
what are the challenges,
what are the solutions.
Also she's taking part
in this European policy process.
Meeting people was one goal of this
conference. That was accomplished.
I met a lot of people
from many countries.
Many nice, young, committed people.
In spite of our different languages,
the communication went very well.
I think that through engaging in
discussions with policymakers,
both learn.
I think that policymakers, they learn
more of the reality of young people
and young people also they can maybe
have a more complex view
on how policymaking works.
One example that illustrates quite well
how policymaking
or Structured Dialogue works
is the Youth Guarantee.
The current scheme of the Youth
Guarantee that is being implemented
in almost all the Member States
is something that appeared also
in the Structured Dialogue’s national
consultations and youth conferences.
So this is something I can say
that can be traced back among others
to the Structured Dialogue.
It looks very complicated, but
it's much more accessible than it seems.
This is a new opportunity to learn
new things, to get more chances.
To build a brighter future for ourselves.